in general if a new virus emerges
um the it seems like the null hypothesis
um that is to say the default hypothesis
that is to say the thing that is
most likely to be true absent evidence
the contrary
is that it is a natural origin right and
that seems to be although i've never
seen
anyone say that in this year that we've
been living with this
that seems to be sort of implied in a
lot of the arguments you know
extraordinary ideas extraordinary claims
require
extraordinary evidence what's your
evidence for lab leak as if
the you know pangolin mediated wet
market
story uh is a parsimonious null
hypothesis which frankly it never was um
and you came to dinner maybe one time
this week and said
okay that but maybe in this case
natural origin should not be the null
hypothesis yeah i mean
i'm not saying it should or it shouldn't
but the point is the assumption that it
should is obviously
uh absurd i do want to go back and say i
heard eric say on clubhouse last night
something that i have uh often said
myself i don't know if i've said it on
darkhorse but
this idea of extraordinary claims
require extraordinary evidence
not a scientific principle right in fact
the rules of engagement
are perfectly clear right and the point
is i don't
care how extraordinary the claim is is
you know is the hypothesis
better supported by the evidence and are
there any other hypotheses if not
it's a theory if it is better supported
but there are other viable hypotheses
than it is one it is the best supported
hypothesis but yeah i hope you could
detect the mockery in my
in my language when i said that but you
know it is one of these things that
trotted out as if it's
a scientific rejoinder to something you
said well
scientific claims require a sign
extraordinary claims require
extraordinary evidence
not right inherently no um and
if correlation is not evidence of
causation
what is so this little brain teaser
correlation is in fact evidence of
causation if there was a causal
hypothesis
pre-existing the observation of the
correlation correlation
sorry correlation is evidence of
causation when preceded
by hypothesis that predicted the
correlation yep
i mean that's that's it right yep that
is it
so in any case there are all of these
little landmines distributed across the
landscape but in this case so we're
going to get in trouble
as always happens when i talk about null
hypothesis in this informal
um philosophical way because
null hypothesis has a very narrow
definition with respect to
a statistical test and in this case i'm
not talking about a statistical test
what i'm talking about is the default
assumption right
we can say the default assumption for a
new
virus is that it emerged uh you know
zoonotically
right now that's not necessarily true
because we could say is that true
for new york right if i see a new virus
that i haven't seen in my clinic in new
york
is the default assumption that it has
emerged from
an animal here in new york no the
default is assumption
assumption is it probably came in at the
airport or the train station or over one
of the bridges or something like that it
came from somewhere else so the point is
you could make the argument that the
default hypothesis
uh would be zoonotic emergence but in
that case no there's a
more uh there's a clearly more likely
possibility in any locale
well yeah it's a zoonotic emergence but
with an additional step added
to account for the geographic
unlikelihood
of a you know a spillover event in the
middle of a major city
right which gets to the analogy that i
came to dinner
shaking my fist at the air uh about
which was this and i
i haven't been to a circus in a very
long time
i hope they no longer use bears but the
idea of the analogy is
were you let's say in downtown dallas
maybe you're at the uh you're at the
target you're in the target parking lot
and the circus is in town and a bear
wanders by right you could say
that the null hypothesis is that the
bear has emerged from nature but there
are no grizzlies
in in texas at this point
and there is a circus and it might have
bears the
obvious first assumption and the one
that any rational person knowing the
circus was in town and having seen a
bear walk across the parking lot
would make is maybe the bear got away
from the circus or the zoo right
and the point about this is in the case
of the wuhan institute of virology
we have this exact case it's more subtle
because you can't see
viruses and so where they are and aren't
isn't familiar
but we don't have these beta
coronaviruses circulating in horseshoe
bats near
wuhan right they're kilometers away
in yunnan right what we do have in wuhan
is an institute that brings those
viruses in to study them
right and so the point is we have been
sold the idea
that the uh the burden of proof
is on the hypothesis that suggests
anything other than zoonotic emergence
but in this case there's a strong
argument to be made that
standing in wuhan and observing this
pandemic break out
that actually the default assumption
probably is that it came from the place
in wuhan where these viruses actually
are known to exist
and not um that it is uh
zoonotic in origin and previously
undetected in any case
i'm not going to say that is but i'm
going to say
the uh the the argument that is deployed
that obviously this um
the hypothesis that the virus came from
the wuhan
institute is so extraordinary that it
requires
overwhelming evidence before we even
begin to talk about it
is nonsense it's clearly one of the
hypotheses that belongs on the table
i would argue that the one with the
burden of proof is the
is the more extraordinary of them which
in this case
it would be that a you know zoonotic
emergence happened without our detection
refined the virus turned it into an uh a
virus that transmits
very well between human beings and then
suddenly showed up without leaving any
evidence that we can see
uh in wuhan right near the wuhan
institute
yeah so i mean you're in fact arguing
that the
loudly hypothesis sort of has some
parsimony already built in on the basis
of
some of the evidence that we can see
even without the help of any of the
potential players on the ground there
and it looks like we're not likely to
get any help from the potential players
on the ground there so
the evidence is going to require some
sleuthing but
it seems more parsimonious uh
at from the starting gate well it seems
more parsimonious from the starting gate
and we now have a history it's not a
real long history
right we're talking about one year but
you know we had these hypotheses
traveling in parallel and yes one of
them faced a whole hell of a lot of
stigma
that one remains consistent with all of
the evidence that has accumulated
in the intervening period you know what
has not
the natural origins hypothesis
you know involved a story that now uh is
strongly suspect on at least two counts
right the
the wet market and the pangolins so um
the point is over time one of these
hypotheses is getting stronger
one of them is getting weaker and you
know doesn't mean it couldn't turn
around tomorrow but
um you know at some level
it was clearly a hypothesis in need of
testing and
those who tried to shut it down did the
world no service
i guess i want to try to be a little
maybe a little bit more careful than
that because i don't think that that is
the
that is the fair comparison between the
two hypotheses that
lab leak from
one of the labs in wuhan
leaves a lot of the details on un
described
right and there are several that we have
talked about ourselves and sometimes
publicly
and it could go a lot of different ways
you know it could be gain of function it
could like it
there could be a lot of particulars
there and
natural zoonotic spillover event is i
think
more appropriately the right comparison
so what we were sold
you know a year ago was you know luon
wet market and pangolin and that had a
high level of specificity which is part
of why it seemed like oh well
scientists know it's pangolin wow what
are the chances right
but you know so the details of the thing
that was sold
to us um inappropriately
um so strongly early on have fallen by
the wayside but i would say that we that
really
you know to compare similar type similar
like levels of granularity of hypotheses
we want like lab leak and natural
zoonotic spill over
and i know i still agree with you i
think you know lab leak looks like
it is more appropriate the null
hypothesis here um but lab like compared
to
you know wuhan wet market spillover from
horseshoe bat to
pangolin to human um is is unfairly
stacking the deck against that
as a possibility yep i mean i take your
point and i think philosophically it's
the right one which is that you need to
compare
things of similar levels of precision
yeah
but at some level the way i would do
that is i would say
you know lab leak is a cluster
of hypotheses as people saw on the
diagram that i put up
as is zonatic spillover yes and
the um
the question is does anything
in zone a stand up yeah
lab leak is zone 8 does anything in zone
a remain consistent with all of the
information that we have
as of this date and then we can do the
same trick over here of all the kinds of
zoonotic spillover is anything still
completely consistent
and the problem is that the
things within zoonotic spillover that
are completely consistent with
everything we know
so far would have to be extraordinary i
think that's the thing
that uh has me animated is that
you could tell a story that would
explain every piece of data
that we have about uh sars co v2
that would be consistent with zoonotic
spillover but it'd be quite a story and
the chances that it happened without
leaving any evidence that we would have
yet found even though the chinese at
least are feeling tremendous pressure to
find a zoonotic explanation
seems very unlikely again nothing here
is conclusive
but um in terms of figuring out how to
feel about it
to the extent that you've been brow
beaten into believing
that um those who talk about lab leaks
are uh wild eyed oh sorry we need to
cover this i think
okay it turns out we have learned in
talking bravely about this
question that there is a
misunderstanding
amongst people who evaluate these
various possibilities and that the deck
has weirdly been stacked
against the idea of lab leak because
people think what is being suggested is
much more extraordinary
than what is actually likely to have
happened so
to the extent that people when they hear
did the virus come from a lab and they
imagine that the allegation has
something to do with this
virus having been assembled in a lab for
a purpose
right that it's either a completely
synthetic virus
uh or you know that it was built up like
lego-wise
and it's not that that's not a component
right we have chimeraism
which can be used to take strengths from
one naturally occurring virus and
strains from another naturally occurring
virus
and put them into a single virus that
has both strengths right but i've not
seen
anyone compellingly argue that this was
created from scratch there is a it
originally in a
bat virus backbone to this thing no
matter what
right maybe it's entirely bad virus with
spillover maybe it's
bat virus backbone but this other thing
that some people are coming back at us
anyway and saying like are you kidding
me
um like no literally no one as far as i
can tell
seriously proposing that right literally
no one no it's overwhelmingly similar to
ratg13
which turns out to be four nine nine one
which is
another piece of evidence that something
fishy is going on here again described
what was ridley and shandpaper that
we'll link to right which
people should read but the point is what
is being hypothesized
with respect to a lab leak is not
out of the range of what we know was
going on
in the wuhan institute in other words
these techniques
are known they're extraordinary but
extraordinary does not mean
that we are guessing we actually know
because they published
the various labs involved in this work
published
reports on what they were doing so we
know that all of these techniques exist
we know that they were being applied
but i mean i guess again to get back to
like
what do evolutionary biologists have to
say about this like the nature of this
research is precisely
we are going to pass the virus through
different selective environments
and see what pops out it is not
conclusion driven it is not like we are
trying to get to there maybe maybe
they're trying to
but there's it's actually like hands off
let's see what mutations
pop out and what sticks and you know
that that is exactly evolutionary
evolutionary process
like it is there is no other way to
describe it
and the i think the uncareful
unnuanced image that people have in
their heads that unfortunately many
virologists many people doing this kind
of research are happy to have people
imagine
is oh you've got a technique and so you
know that when you want to have
virus a with b in it you just go chunk
and like yes there is some of that there
is some of the chimerism um chimerism
but
the gain of function research the serial
passaging
is not like that it does exactly produce
results that you cannot completely
control
not only not completely control but
effectively evolution is being used to
do things that we don't yet know how to
do
exactly so um and we don't know what
we'll get and we don't know what all the
effects will be
and we have no way to control them if
they happen
so the importance of this
would be hard to overstate now you
mentioned i think
i think you actually mixed two papers
there's a lancet paper and a
nature paper that both showed up very
early to
um shut down any inquiry into the idea
of lab leakage
the lancet paper was like the many many
signatories you're right with
uh dasic on it the nature paper
made the following argument
it made the argument that although
the the receptor binding domain
of sars cov2 is very well adapted
to bind the protein in question
we did not know enough to make the
protein that way
anybody who knew what they were doing
would not have made the protein
this way therefore it must be natural
yes which is a nonsense argument in
light of the fact that you've got gain
of function research to
accomplish what you wouldn't know to ask
precisely so question
are the scientists doing this research
that confused about the research they
are doing that they themselves
don't recognize the power of what they
are doing and how it works
or are they being intentionally
deceitful either way
either way you need people who actually
understand the tools that they're using
and the implications
um if they're going to be do allowed to
do this kind of research at all again
remember there was a moratorium on this
research in the u.s from
for four years just lifted at the
beginning of the trump administration
and that that claim
i'm sure i don't know where it was
picked up but i'm sure that was part of
what contributed to the
see there's no way this could be lab
leak we don't know enough to do that
yes but you know what we do know how to
do we know how to play god well enough
to set evolution on a problem and say go
to it
yeah sick it evolution and it and it
happens
and we do we cannot predict what's going
to happen downstream
so in effect what we have is
a piece of non-evidence the fact that we
could not have
specified in advance the um
the sequence that we wanted or that
nobody who knew a lot about this would
have specified it because it would have
sounded like it wouldn't have worked
very well
yeah and that it was actually it was
that even weaker claim actually
no one would have done this right no
reasonable person would have done this
well no we're not saying any reasonable
person did it we're saying evolution is
cleverer than reasonable people
and um you know so but here's the thing
the paper i believe it's christian
anderson's paper in nature
is still used to silence people who say
the lab leak hypothesis
is viable right the fact of there being
a paper in a
major journal peer-reviewed that claims
that this
is solid evidence doesn't matter that it
has been
it has been illustrated to be nonsense
because it is not responsive to what
actually is
imagined to have happened right that's a
very important fact
[Music]
you